this year this year we've covered many
depressing aspects of our criminal
justice system from how mandatory
minimum sentencing is crowded our
prisons to how Bale punishes the poor to
how overstretched public defenders
threaten your right to a fair trial to
how small municipal violations can wind
up putting you in the barrel and
fun fact if you binge watch those
episodes in order you are entitled to an
ice cream cone at Dairy Queen
so congratulations enjoy it you have
earned it just to be clear it's not free
and Dairy Queen is not involved in any
capacity the point is though after
learning about our shattered justice
system you frankly earned the right to
eat your feelings with a peanut Buster
parfait the only frozen Treat in America
with nut buster as part of its name
anyone tonight instead of talking about
how people wind up in prison I thought
we talked about how they leave a process
known as prison re-entry it's
particularly relevant this week in light
of what happened just last weekend the
largest one-time release of federal
prisoners in history is getting underway
today the move is in response to a
loosening of mandatory minimum sentences
for nonviolent drug offenders about
6,000 prisoners are being set free today
yes 6,000 mostly low-level drug
offenders were released last week and if
you are one of them let me bring you up
to speed on what you may have missed
since you've been inside um Uber's
replace cabs everyone pretends to like
kale now Matthew McConaughey has an
Oscar and in four states pot is legal
which for some of you must seem like a
cruel cruel irony
now unsurprisingly this news was not
exactly welcomed by everyone
when you release people like that you're
going to have an increase in crime okay
no doubt my mind
some believe the prisoner release is a
racial deal that will put Americans in
jeopardy it's part of an effort to
reduce prison overcrowding but who
exactly are these prisoners are they
dangerous yes are they dangerous is this
the purge is it happening is this the
Pope what what do I need to buy a mask
or will one be provided for me I don't
know how the purge works now now to be
clear by and large these prisoners were
going to be released in a couple of
years anyway so people are essentially
freaking out about something that had it
happened two years later they wouldn't
even have noticed and it's also worth
noting that more than 600,000 people get
released from state and federal prisons
every year so 6,000 more would represent
an increase of less than 1% and the only
time anyone actually notices a change
that small is your dad with the
thermostat and hey when you have your
own place you can heat it like the
tropics but not what he's paying the
bills and fought you're burning money
unfortunately we have a lot of
misconceptions about what leaving prison
is actually like perhaps because it's
often presented in movies and TV as a
happy moment when former inmates rejoin
families and friends and put their life
back together real wort I never thought
I'd get out there's a good young good
hug it was important that we cut a deal
and Kenny was finally free
oh that's so nice although the last
thing was slightly undercut when Patrick
the starfish realized spongebob had
joined the Aryan Brotherhood 1 inside
hey hey he did what he had to do he did
what he had to do but but the sad truth
is for a surprisingly high number of
prisoners their time on the outside may
be brief the national average of
recidivism is 50% so we're spending 80
billion dollars and failing half the
time right that doesn't make any sense
no it doesn't make any sense the only
thing we're allowed to throw billions
out just to fail half the time is this
man
vandalized urban outfitters mannequin
Johnny Depp the fact that around half of
people who leave prison end up going
back is horrifying but when you look at
the challenges they face it gets a
little less surprising in fact let me
walk you through what it's like when you
get out of prison and let's just start
with minute one because when inmates
exit that gate to start a new life they
could find themselves in the middle of
nowhere with little to nothing in their
pockets and the lucky ones might get
enough for a bus ticket and a meal but
even exonerated prisoners like Glen Ford
can walk out with little to build a life
on Glen Ford was given a $20 gift card
the day he left Angola prison gave me a
card for $20 and said wish you luck
how long did that last year one meal had
some fried chicken tea and the French
fries came with it I had four dollars
and change left a twenty dollar gift
card if you're exonerated you should
probably believe in prison
with more than you take home after a
disappointing office Secret Santa and
hey don't don't act surprised that that
gift was terrible your name got picked
by Janice from accounting and you know
she don't give up
she don't give up how about you and look
once your money runs out you can find
yourself hungry and desperate because in
many states anyone with felony drug
convictions can be banned from
government food benefits and if your
family lives in public housing you may
not be able to return home because some
places require tenants to sign papers
banning relatives with convictions from
entering their homes and while those
rules may have been written to reduce
crime in public housing they're
administered so broadly it can lead to
situations like this
Geraldine Miller signed the ban after
her son robbed a bodega at 16 had I
didn't know what I know today I would
have never signed that paper Miller
herself now faces eviction after her son
was caught helping her with groceries
after she became ill she has to go to
her brother's apartment to see her son
my true want me to throw my son away I
can't I can't look we all want people
who've committed crimes to learn their
lesson but never help your sick mother
with groceries sounds more like the kind
of lesson you'd learn from a shitty Boy
Scout leader their kids never help your
sick mother with groceries always know
where the exits are in a dogfight
and never pay a stripper upfront scouts
dismissed and restricted access to food
and shelter could be just the beginning
of your problems depending on where you
live a felony conviction can cut you off
from everything from voting to a
driver's license - and this is true one
Florida County's home weatherization
program so I guess Florida is perfectly
happy to put people behind bars but they
draw the line at putting them behind
storm windows and insulation and while
you could pay for food shelter and
weatherization with a job your
opportunities to get one of those might
be severely limited there are state and
local bands preventing ex-felons from
working as everything from a nurse to a
septic tank cleaner - in Mississippi an
alligator rancher as if breaking into
the alligator ranching business wasn't
already hard enough as it is
you know I taught it's all who you know
who's been eaten by an alligator in that
guy
and a criminal record can even make
getting an interview for a job difficult
nearly every job application will ask a
potential employee if he or she has ever
been convicted of a felony a question
that in some cases will automatically
disqualify you from getting hired and
makes you a little uncomfortable you get
that anxiety when you get to that box
slave Wow
how they gonna judge me you know know
that I committed this crime how they're
gonna feel about this and it's
understandable that an employer might
want to know if an applicant has a
criminal history but to have that
question on a form before you've even
met the person seems a little unfair
they may have changed significantly
since then and you shouldn't judge
someone and what they may be most
ashamed of imagine if you had once
a watermelon maybe it happened 14
years ago you're not proud of it and
you've changed since then if every job
application you filled out had this
question on it with no opportunity to
give context about drunky were or the
fact you haven't even looked at a
watermelon for over a decade you'd begin
to feel like the deck was stacked
against you and some states seem to even
acknowledge how hard this process can be
Ohio actually has a list of job tips for
ex-offenders with do's and don'ts such
as do be honest but if you're asked why
you left your last job don't use
negative words like went to jail instead
do use terms like relocated or contract
ended both of these are true and they
are and before you judge that is not a
lie everyone tries to present the most
flattering image of themselves you do it
when you use a filter on an Instagram
photo of yourself even the Queen does it
because this is her official portrait
but this is who she actually is but deep
down she knows you can't put that face
on money
and all of this is before we get to the
difficulty of ex-prisoners navigating
parole 2/3 of parolees who go back to
prison do so not due to a new crime but
because of parole violations sometimes
for reasons as simple as missing
appointments or failing a drug test and
for some it may be because they're
dealing with untreated substance abuse
or mental illness but for others who are
trying their hardest satisfying the
conditions of parole can be maddeningly
difficult look at Bilal Chatman he spent
a decade in prison for a nonviolent drug
offense but despite the odds he managed
to get his life back on track and find a
job that he loved things were going well
until he hit a problem regarding
scheduling meetings with his probation
officer so he got off I think every day
about 4:00 and so my job didn't I think
it off till 4:30 I said okay what can I
come in early said no you can't come in
early I said what cable can I come a
little later can I get through at like 5
if you leave at 4:30 I don't stay and
wait for you I'm not gonna wait for you
so I don't want to lose my job this is
the things that I'm supposed to be doing
this is what I'm out here for so I'm
working to be a productive member of
society I felt it I felt set up I felt
like I was set up to fail I thought most
people in that situation or set are set
up to fail and you know what it is hard
to argue with that because the only way
Bilal could make an appointment at 4:00
if he left at 4:30
would be if he somehow owned a DeLorean
a TARDIS or whatever the John
Claude Van Damme used in Timecop
I can't remem I think he travelled
through time by doing the splits it's
been a while but I think it was a split
based system
also depending on where you live you
might not just struggle to meet your to
meet your parole officer you might
struggle to pay him because in many
states you actually have to pay for
probation and parole service and in
Pennsylvania they charged us $60 fee
just to enter the program and if you
don't have the money for all the fees
they charge as one Pennsylvania parolee
explains you can be forced to make a
truly ridiculous choice
you also see your parole officer you
don't have money it will hold you job or
no job and if you don't pay you come out
to Joe yeah I know one thing I found
myself southern drug to pay back to
civilian oh god so in order to pay for
the program to keep him away from
dealing drugs he has to earn money drug
dealing at this point the Pennsylvania
Department of Corrections might as well
change its motto to y'all come back now
you're here by now you may be wondering
who is responsible for a system this
broken well interestingly the answer is
pretty much everybody many of the
obstacles you've seen originated in the
tough-on-crime 90s with surprisingly
little debate remember the ban on ex
prisoners from entering public housing
which forced Geraldine Miller to kick
out her son well here's where that
started from now on the rule for
residents who commit crime and peddle
drugs should be one strike and you're
out
that is a state of the union standing
ovations from both sides almost nothing
gets a full room standing ovations
during those speeches with the exception
of veterans God and the speech being
over in many cases these laws were
passed with barely a second thought the
1996 law letting States restrict food
stamps for extra gallons was debated in
the Senate for all of three minutes I've
been talking about this subject for
nearly five times longer than they did
and I'm leaving a lot of stuff out
mainly because I had to make time for
Timecop references and frankly as well
no one batted an eye when bart gordon a
Democrat from Tennessee justified
cutting off federal student aid for
prisoners with this logic just because
one bland hog may occasionally find an
acorn doesn't mean many other blind hogs
will the same principle applies to
giving federal pell grants to prisoners
first of all pigs find nuts by smell so
a blind one is at no significant
disadvantage in an acorn hunt and second
of all people aren't pigs you
and look I know I know
it is not it's not always easy to care
about the welfare of ex-prisoners and
some are going to re offend no matter
what you do but the fact remains over
95% of all prisoners will eventually be
released so it's in everyone's interest
that we try to give them a better chance
at success because under the current
system if they do manage to overcome all
the obstacles we've set it's a minor
miracle and one of the people who have
managed to beat those odds is Bilal
Chapman I'm happy to say that he is
still in his job and he's still doing
well and I'm even happy to say he's
actually with us this evening so please
welcome Bill Chappell please sit down
fill out fill out oh thank you so much
for coming tonight I know that you were
not sure about doing this so I want to
thank you for being here yes
now you managed to keep the job that you
were talking about in that clip and we
saw the state of Ohio giving advice to
prisoners about how to present their
truth and when you when you apply for
jobs you listed your previous employer
as what did you list state of California
the state of California that's right
that is yeah that's technically true
lettuce that's true that's true
yeah um now I know how is the job going
absolutely fantastic I couldn't I
couldn't script it another way
in any way better than what's going on
I'm very excited I'm very fortunate and
blessed
they've given me this opportunity yes I
am dedicated to them you know absolutely
one of and I know I know that you one of
the reasons you're nervous is that
because not everyone you work for or
with knows about the fact that you were
once in prison now you're going to work
tomorrow morning they may know by then
yes
so I guess guess what I want to know is
what what particularly are you most
worried about I got some more worried
about being judged for what it used to
be I'm not that same person you know
I've dedicated myself up I changed
myself I'm no longer that person you
know as time goes on you become you know
I become a better person
I've worked
hardly the things that that I've taken
from society and so yeah so what what
are the concerns that they'll what they
will think or how they might behave what
does this spectrum of circumstances that
you concerned I guess some more people
are judgmental people that don't know
you know I don't want anybody look at me
as the ex-con I want them to look at me
as a person I am now I'm a supervisor
you know I'm a good employee I'm an
employer I even hire and I fire right so
I think they want I want them to look at
me as that continue live that they were
about to both cheer and boo you when you
okay I guess that was interesting you
say that right that you don't want to be
defined by something that you did so
long ago because we're probably guilty
of giving you a reductive term in that
way because we're having you on tonight
as Bilal the ex-prisoner right which is
clearly not who you've been for a long
time right now everyone has at least
three other things about them that are
interesting what what three things about
you not related to that would you like
people to know well I don't like people
to know you know well you know I'm grow
tomatoes you like wait wait I'm gonna
stop you
yeah I'm going to stop you at number one
fair Bilal cos that's a lot more
interesting than I think you think it is
no I'm hoping that tomorrow you're in
your fellow workers may choose really
mainly to focus on the fact you grow
tomatoes right as being a more
interesting part of your life I know
that one of the things that's
interesting is that I know how hesitant
you were to do this we talked to you
through the week yes as we even talked
to you today and tonight I guess a
question would be why why did you end up
talking to us what why are you here
I'm here because it affected um you know
I may never do this again
I've done other interviews I mean I
would do this again because this takes
me back to being that prisoner again I'm
not that prisoner today I'm a taxpayer
you know I work I'm a citizen I'm a
voter that's who I want to be those are
the things that have defined me today
it's not what I did before I did things
years ago then I'm ashamed of you know
that I don't like but I don't want to
relive that at the same time I want this
opportunity to be for someone who says
oh man I can never get a chance I'll
never have a chance there's always a
chance we just keep going but I want the
person also that looks at down at us
that maybe there's a chance for other
people too
that's right I thought fill out I can't
thank you enough for taking the time to
be here Bilal Chatman later the tomato
grower
you